Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 26 2018 what's going on?
How,
how's it going everybody?
How are you?
Do Da,
how the fucking pucker you.
Um,
while I'm back,
everybody vacation is officially over.
I have shit to do every frigging day of this week.
You know,
why?
Why Bill?
Cause you actually have to go to work.
You're lazy contact
every once in a while.
I want to share my feelings and I appreciate if you will reciprocate.
Um,
F is for family is coming out on Netflix this Wednesday,
November 29th.
Please watch,
please watch again.
Please watch with all your friends or don't do whatever the fuck you want to do.
I think it's going to be,
I think you're going to enjoy it.
You know,
you're listening to this.
I think you'd enjoy it.
Um,
you know what I would enjoy if somebody could tell me how I can buy a quality
quality.
You know what?
Maybe it's just these fucking headphones.
Maybe it's just as Jack,
whatever.
Let's continue promoting knowing that people can hear me.
But I can't hear myself.
And when you can't hear yourself,
how are you going to be able to open up to others?
That's the question that we want to talk about here today.
Um,
it's going to be on November 29th.
It's fucking going to be on Netflix though,
right?
That's the deal.
Let's see what we got here.
Let's try to put this in here and let's see if this fixes the problem.
How about this new headphones?
You know,
most people,
if they were a professional,
they woulda hit pause by now.
That's not me,
is it not?
That's not how bill does it.
Bill just keeps going.
And why would you,
what do you know?
It still doesn't fucking work.
Does anybody know who?
Who the fuck makes a Goddamn fucking headphone Jack that's of quality?
You know,
you go down a guitar center.
Thank you.
Fucking buy the Goddamn fucking mixture when it works and then everything else
fucking sucks.
Yeah,
it doesn't make any sense.
You go to a Lexus dealership,
everything's at the fucking Lexus level.
Unfucking believable.
It is fucking bullshit.
I've been bitching about this for fucking two Goddamn fucking months.
You know all the dumb shit that I do with my life.
Oh,
the fucking bars.
I go into your take one night,
you take a fucking night off and go buy a fucking headphone Jack
[inaudible] efforts and family is going to be a lot of that.
If that's what you're into.
Hey,
does anybody know where the fuck I can fucking go and buy some shit that wasn't
made in fucking China is they're passive aggressive fucking way to say fuck you
to my country.
Is anything made in this fucking Goddamn fucking country anymore?
The fact that this fucking thing,
I just bought this and then you can sell this and they would have,
fuck,
am I going to call,
call some fucking guy in India who's pretending like he's here and then he can
do this fucking bullshit.
I'm chill.
I be sure I'm you feel that way?
I
understand.
Get the fuck out of here.
Okay.
By the way,
I know your name is Todd.
Ah.
It feels good to blow out the lines every once in a while.
Everybody over over something that you totally have power over.
Um,
anyways,
this is what I do now.
I just yell at things.
I don't yell at people anymore.
I just,
you know,
you well,
you know what I like when you yell at an inanimate object,
you feel like it's listening.
You know,
cause it never interrupts.
Never tells you you're wrong.
All right.
Anyways,
efforts or family is going to be up November 29th on Netflix.
Please watch it.
Also,
uh,
the seventh annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit tickets going fast.
Loving it.
Tuesday,
February 19th at 7:00 PM at the city center in New York City.
A lineup.
Jim Gaffigan,
big Jay Oakerson.
Gary Gulman,
Chris read Michelle Wolf.
SIFA sounds rich.
Vos is hosting and yours too.
Oh,
freckles.
All fucking freckles with is fucked up headphones.
I'm not the headphones.
It's the God damn check stuff.
Fucking Jag.
BOMP bomp bomp bone.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
um,
so this week I got to do this,
this inner,
this Skype interview with this coffee company.
All right.
And uh,
I fucking hate,
I hate Skype.
I fucking hate it.
You know what,
he Skypes in another one.
Those fucking things on your computer that wants you downloaded.
Every time you turn your computer on it fucking sticks.
It's fucking Goddamn face out there.
It's like,
Hey,
did I click on you?
Did I click on you?
They'd say,
shut up.
Yeah,
I got this other thing right.
I got to,
I got this external hard drive thing.
I used it one time.
Every time I shut down my computer and turn it back on again.
It's like that fucking,
you know,
you know that person at the party when you just sitting there like,
who invited this guy?
That's what all of those apps are like.
You know,
we need to make sure every time they turn on your computer that this comes on
and we remind them that it's on your computer.
Well,
it makes me want to do is eventually grab that icon or whatever the fuck you
call it and drag it over to the trashcan.
And my favorite thing ever is when you hit the Lee trash,
that little poof,
they're little poof of dust,
you know?
Would you like?
I'm going to be,
wouldn't it be great if you could do that to the guy at the party?
You just fucking big paper,
machete Arrow.
You put it on them and you poke them in his belly.
He giggles and then he just,
he just disappears and he can get back to the cool conversation you were having.
Or maybe you are just sitting there enjoying yourself in the corner and he
decided that he was going to be,
you know,
I'm a social guy,
I'm just going to come up and say hello.
Rather than seeing that somebody clearly is over in the corner not wanting to
talk to anybody.
I'm going to go over there and go fucking talk to him.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno that.
I mean maybe that's just a fucking
white thing.
The way we fucking walk up to wild animals and shit.
Maybe we,
it's,
it starts at the party by going over to the person in the corner who clearly has
some sort of fucking issues.
Clearly not a PR person.
You want to steer clear of.
You gotta walk up,
you walk up,
you say alo,
and because of the rules of society over there,
this guy doesn't rip your fucking head off.
And then you just,
Oh,
I think maybe I'll apply the same annoying behavior I use at a party into the
wild.
Maybe I'll do that.
Hey,
polar bear.
I'm going to come and be an open fucking spirit.
Yeah.
The amount of,
you know,
I follow that,
uh,
discover sharks on Instagram,
the amount of fucking morons that are so into sharks that trying to prove how
not dangerous they are and they're fucking jumping in the water with them.
It's like he didn't,
you didn't watch the crocodile hunter.
That's what the fuck he did.
Do you think you know nature better than that guy?
Yeah.
Do the way that guy got killed.
That was like a great episode of the wire.
You just didn't see it coming.
You know what I mean?
All those years fucking with those ridiculously ridiculously poison snakes and
may get snakes and fucking Australia that could be take out a small country with
one bite,
the entire fucking population.
And this guy's going over there with his fucking booty shorts on with aerobics
socks.
Fucking with these things.
You think in one of these days this guy is going to get bit and his shapely Tan
calves right now didn't happen.
All right.
Maybe it's going to be,
I don't know that.
What else did he fuck with some sort of fucking wild boar?
That's what you thought was going to get them.
Certainly a fucking crocodile.
You know,
you thought that would get them in one ended up fucking getting them a goddamn
sting.
Ray never saw that coming.
That was just like the wire.
Well,
what's his face?
Oh my God,
I forgot the iconic fucking,
the guy used to rob the drug dealers.
I'm not going to ruin it.
I'm not spoiler alert.
It's been a spoiler alert.
It's been out for fucking 15 years or whatever.
I'm not going to ruin the ending.
But the way that guy,
you know what happens to him,
you just don't fucking see it coming.
MMM.
I don't even know what I'm talking about anymore.
But anyways,
I'm doing a,
one of my favorite people,
one of my favorite podcasts of all time.
This Wednesday I'm going to be on the Joe Rogan experience.
I'm also doing dice Clay's podcasts,
uh,
later on that day and I'm finally calling in to spit and check what's on
Barstool.
All right.
I'm running the gambit.
Okay.
The gamut of podcasts that day.
I'm doing Kevin and being on Friday
and that's local out here.
If you live in La local radio,
I'm sure they have an app that you can download and listen to it wherever the
fuck you want to.
And then what else?
I've got a couple of folders tomorrow,
but I now you have to download fucking Skype so I can do this phone or today at
noon so then I can then immediately fucking delete it again.
Don't forget about me.
I'm on your computer.
We know Skype.
Everybody knows you here.
Everybody knows you're fucking here.
The only thing,
one,
one positive thing I will say about Skype as I love the phone ring.
[inaudible] I don't know what it is about it.
I like it.
I like,
other than,
than that,
everything about it is a
all right.
It's fucking annoying.
You know what I mean?
Um,
anyways,
how was your Thanksgiving [inaudible] joy use the,
I already talked about thanksgiving.
I forgot I did it on Friday.
Talk Friday.
What,
what are you gonna talk about?
Let's talk about the debacle.
If you are a wolverines fan that was Michigan,
Ohio state,
Jesus fucking Christ.
That was just,
that was just a,
sorry fucking,
they should have beat them this year.
They really should have,
you know something.
As much as the buckeyes are walking around with their chest puffs out,
it's like you let up 40 fucking points.
I don't know what you're so excited about.
Fucking unbelievable,
man.
I swear to God,
if those cons didn't get that fucking ridiculous spot two years ago,
it would have been a rivalry again.
Nowaday,
they just,
they just got the psychological advantage that fucking gave two years ago when
everybody,
I'll let you tie.
Officiating Squad was from fucking Ohio.
I think he got the first day or whatever the fuck it was.
Anyways,
I just wanted a game is what I wanted and I wanted hard blah to win one.
So then you could have the fucking urban Meyer Harbach 10 years war,
but now you know,
I dunno,
urban Meyers got some sort of cyst in his head.
I had no fucking idea.
I didn't know that.
So it's just like,
yeah,
dude,
you got a,
you got a wife and kids,
what are you doing here?
You know,
every time they run the ball for a lost,
the guy literally has to fucking bend over to his ankles.
He gets headaches when he flips out and it's just like,
it's like,
it's literally a ticking time budge.
It's,
am I going to say it's unsettling to watch.
You know what I mean?
Jesus Christ.
But then it's like,
what is he going to do?
Just sit at home with his sister being pleasant.
I mean,
the man has to live his fucking life,
right?
MMM.
Anyways,
what else?
What did we talked about?
We've talked about headphone Jack.
He's talked about sis in people's heads.
Um,
yeah,
patriots jets.
That was the one football game.
I watched that one.
And I watched the,
uh,
watch the end of the Steelers game and it was tough to watch big Ben.
Uh,
lose that one.
Man.
I saw two fucking amazing quarterbacks have tough games.
Aaron Rogers had that guy open and then a big band,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm talking like I would have fucking made the past,
but
um,
I'm so out of it right now.
Like I was actually rooting for the Steelers cause the,
just,
I fucking hate the Broncos just because they kicked our ass from Craig Morton,
right through John Elway.
And I'm still not over it
every fucking time in edits.
Every fucking time we play him.
It's always an away game.
We've always back in their horseshoe,
back in the day,
it'd be freezing fucking cold out.
It would start snowing and then we would just get the shit kicked out.
And we all in,
every time we played them,
it was just be like,
you know,
we had hope and it had some sort of playoff implications and then that would be
it.
That's the old,
you know,
that's the old Boston sports fan.
As opposed to now where everybody's mean.
Anybody born from the ninth,
1990 on is just absolutely spoiled.
Um,
as far as being the page us,
uh,
a Boston sports fan,
which I'm totally fine with.
Um,
I watched a little bit of Celtics,
caught a little bit of the Bruins verse the Canadians and um,
I don't know.
I just had it.
I had a great weekend,
man.
I really had a great weekend.
I tell you,
I think I told you that guys.
This did I tell you I took my,
uh,
I told you that last,
last week.
I took my kid to guitar center,
man.
It was fucking awesome.
God knows we didn't buy any fucking headphone Jackson.
Let's fucking idiots.
They're not idiots.
But you did need to know why.
Why?
Why are you selling shit that doesn't fucking work.
Hey Bill,
why didn't you keep the receipt and bring it back?
Because I don't want to fucking make another trip over there.
Yeah.
All right.
I never take the receipt.
I'm not coming back.
Doesn't fucking work.
I'll just yell about it
rather than just getting in my car and solving the problem.
Um,
okay.
You know,
every time I think I turned the corner as a person,
I just realized,
oh Jesus,
it's just like this.
There's another fucking storage shed of emotional shit I have to fucking go
through.
You know,
if,
imagine if they could do that with your personality.
They had this storage wars with you,
right.
And they just make you stand in.
There is a middle aged person and they get a bunch of fucking women out there
looking for a partner and that just bid,
not,
you know,
and then they just,
they opened the door and you're fucking standing there
with your fucking dad jades and your little cut belly trying to suck it in and
it just looking in your eyes.
You're trying not to look away like some wild animals shit,
you know?
Then they start bidding on you.
What do you think they'd been on you?
Let's just say,
you know,
we'll make it easy.
A hundred bucks is like,
this guy looks like the winner top shelf Johnny blue.
I want to be with this guy in zero is this guy's a fucking zero.
This guy's a loser.
Everything he touches turns to Shit,
you know?
What do you think you'd be on that?
I think the only thing that saves me is I earned a good living other,
if you take that out of the equation,
all right.
I think I am.
I'm in the 30s,
depending on how fucking crazy your dad was.
I would say I might even drop down into the 20s.
You know,
I'm looking at an emotional lottery pick the next season.
Uh Oh,
by the way,
um,
you know,
I was talking to Varanasi and he was saying I was fuck this guy's named sake.
Say Quan Barkley was just having like a career day,
almost a hundred yards in the first half or some fucking shit against the
eagles.
And then they ran him four times in the second half and he just couldn't wrap
his head around the fact.
It's like,
dude,
the giants are tanking.
Okay,
they're not going to make the fucking [inaudible].
You know the Patriots it we'd be in trouble,
but they,
they're going to tank people tank.
All right.
Indianapolis.
They tank to get Andrew Luck.
Peyton manning came back.
Hey doctor said I'm good.
Oh No,
Peyton,
we're worried about you.
I will fucking worried about you.
Then Peyton goes on to fucking,
you know,
win a super bowl over there and fucking Denver.
I love that you have in order to said whenever anybody treats this superstar
with absolute disrespect,
that guy ends up in Colorado and wins championships.
If you noticed that the fucking Canadians,
all right,
this scarf where and fucking snooty guide.
Damn fans booed Patrick Wall.
I'm going to say this again.
They booed.
Patrick was a man not only a hall of Famer Natalie Winter of two Stanley cups at
that point,
that DDI change the position.
You're talking about this a handful of fucking people in the history of the NHL.
They can say that I changed the position to Patrick was one of them.
And what did he do?
He went to the Colorado avalanche one,
not one,
but two fucking Stanley cups
and all of those fucking pocket square blue blog,
a rouge cops sport coat wearing concept there.
I still sitting there with the course,
sign up their ass waiting for another cup.
25 fucking years later,
Indianapolis Colts tank a fucking season so they can get Andrew Luck.
Where does Peyton manning go?
Does he try to pile on in San Francisco?
And Jim Harbaugh was there and they will one fucking piece away.
Now he does not.
Pate Manning says,
I'm going to be a fucking man about this.
I've gone to the Goddamn Broncos.
Not saying they were bad,
but that would've been a layup in San Francisco.
It's tough to say.
It would've been a lamp with Jim.
Horrible after that.
Fucking lost the other day.
Bow and I'll put them in the unimaginative fucking play.
Calling run,
play action.
Fake third and long.
Let's throw it.
Um,
way to fucked his way to fuck his pate man and go.
He goes to Denver and it goes to not one,
but two Superbowls gets his ass kicked in the first one.
But I only played Seattle,
you know,
they were all fucking roided up and nobody gave a shit cause they're in Seattle.
That's not cheating.
You know,
it's a competitive edge.
Right.
But he comes back and wins it like the next year or the year,
a year later,
I forget what should write another super
bowl trophy.
Okay.
So I'm thinking that the giants had get a tank this year.
Then they're going to go out,
they're going to draft the fucking quarterback.
They're going to tell Eli winter,
if not one,
but two super bowls against bill Belicheck,
the greatest fucking coach of all time.
They're going to tell him they hit the fucking bricks of,
where do you think that man's going?
Not The Broncos.
He's going to shock everybody's going to play point guard for the Denver Nuggets
and they went an NBA championship.
Right.
Um,
sorry.
what's you're listening to right now is a man who has a lot of Shitty as to do
this week and he doesn't want to get out of bed.
Oh,
was I enjoy in my time off?
did I enjoy it?
You know,
but I realized I was enjoying it too much because I was continuing to,
you know,
have some drinks,
have some cigars,
and what I really realized it was,
Bill,
when you have time off,
what you need to be doing is drinking water and getting eight hours sleep,
then you'll actually feel rested.
Then the vacation won't seem like it went by too quickly.
I realized this last night,
the last day of my vacation.
All right,
but when I'm going to do is I'm going to apply the wisdom that I've learned.
I can't even say wisdom because I have learned this lesson.
I've learned this lesson more fucking times.
And then Ohio state has kicked the fucking shit out of the wolverines in the
last decade and a half.
Um,
anyways,
what's going to happen or how state urban Meyer,
everybody's saying is going to leave this year.
Well,
yeah,
that's not good for football.
You got to give me the date.
It was just building up.
You now are by,
ah,
Harbaugh has to,
Harbaugh has,
whenever smokers had got my voice cracks the next day,
horrible.
I has to fuck it.
He's gotta,
he's gotta get,
he's got a big debt guy.
He can't take his ball and go home off for health reasons.
He can.
You don't,
how about give him shit.
Oh,
is that it buddy?
Huh?
One little fucking cyst and you're going to go home.
Then urban could just walk away going 62,
63,
whatever they fucking scored.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
Now what do I do?
I do with some reads.
Let's do some reads.
That's why I'm reading.
Ah,
read notes on the moon home or one in.
All right.
Five reads everybody.
Not One,
not two.
Like the Stanley cups that Patrick,
while one,
actually the Canadians are playing good this year,
you know,
not good enough for their fan base because they expect things I love.
I love one of fan base expects things out of their professional sports
franchise,
but nothing out of their own personal lives.
That right there,
that is a true sports fan.
Um,
all right,
fine.
Blood sugars box everybody.
Oh Jesus.
Do I love these case.
Butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range.
Organic chicken and the one the only inevitably replaced the,
the the,
the fucking pork that changed the position.
The Patrick Wa of pork heritage,
bread.
Pork.
Now a lot of you like me,
you probably say,
well what exactly is heritage bread?
Pork.
And I know you've explained this well,
guess what?
It's so fucking good.
I'm going to explain it again.
Heritage Badge pork is,
is murdered pigs that are pure bred pigs that you can trace their family tree
all the way back to Europe.
They weren't over here fucking these low rent pigs here in the United States of
America.
You know that sit around watching reality TV while they were eating cotton
candy.
These,
these,
these are European pigs.
They read,
they smoked cigarettes,
holding the cigarette from underneath.
These pigs can ride scooters.
Everybody and I'll do this.
It's incredible.
It's the best takes and pork chop I've ever fucking had.
My mouth literally waters when I read this shit.
Incredible.
Incredible quality of butcher box meat starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones before they are
slaughtered.
Yeah,
they listen to fucking feel good music.
And then one day you just walk up.
Hey,
piggy,
look at that over there.
Then he gave me all right there.
Fred over cook with a piece of,
but the peace of mind knowing you are eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
Unless you're a tub of shit and you're fucking gluttonous and you'd go through
it in three days,
it's your choice.
You know you want to have the meat sweats,
so you want to have abs.
It's all up to you.
You can choose from five different box types,
all beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
Like my new favorite cook there,
Johnny and Johnny,
I live on the hill every morning I walked down to buy what I'm going to cook
that day.
My name is Johnny and this is what's left to the Italian American section in San
Francisco.
I fucking loved that guy.
Next time I go to San Francisco,
I want that guy to come to a show.
MMM.
All right.
Custom Bar,
right?
For $20 off your first box.
And a package of free bacon in every box for life,
for the life of your subscription.
Uh,
go to butcher
box.com/burr and interpret a chicken at checkout.
By the way,
fuck Turkey Bacon.
All right,
that's a little aside.
You know what?
I need to learn how to cook it because I tried to cook it like the pig shit,
you know,
or did you just bathes in its own grease?
I like to burn it up.
By the way,
you know,
my wife's,
I take,
I take it off in about 15 minutes.
You know,
mine,
I,
I leave it in there for another eight minutes.
Um,
all right,
that's $20 off your first box and a package of free bacon in every box for the
life of your subscription by going to butcher box.com/burr and entering burr at
checkout.
All right.
In don't cheat.
Oh,
uh,
mentioned that there's no longer any excuse for wearing ill fitting suits.
Everybody,
you know,
something I just wouldn't just love dimension something.
There is no longer any excuse for wearing an ill fitting suit.
Okay.
It's 2018 I think it's time you fucking grow,
especially when they're available at such great prices.
Highest quality,
lowest price.
Here's how it works.
Visit a
stylist@ourshowroomandhavethemtakeyourmeasurementspersonallyormeasureathomeyourselfandshoponlineatindochino.com
choose your fabric inside and out.
Choose your design customization.
Submit your measurements with your choices.
Relax while your suit gets professionally tailored and mailed to you in a couple
of weeks.
November is black Friday.
Uh,
I think that already happened.
Meaning 2018 is lowest prices,
up to 70% off everything.
The theme is all about stepping out from backstage,
making entrance.
Take Center stage,
your biggest moment,
grand finale,
etc.
This week,
my listeners can have,
can avail of black price black Friday prices by using code [inaudible] at
checkout.
That's 70% off the regular price for a made to measure suit plus shipping is
free.
That's indochino.com Promo Code [inaudible] up to 70% off.
Incredible deal for a made to measure suit.
One should go custom.
You don't go rack.
Hey by the weight.
I don't think anybody got trampled or murdered or killed during black Friday.
I think they finally have it down due to do though.
Me,
undies,
me on Ds.
Nobody fucking died to do to to me,
id be on these.
Although there's fat fucks tried getting pressed up against the glass.
You bellies round with you flat ass.
You got to pancake.
It's not worth it to get the DVD VCR at fucking Walmart.
Yeah,
you're gonna get bludgeoned with a fish tank.
All right.
[inaudible]
this is the year that you can finally tackle your holiday shopping early.
And guess what?
You can get everything you need for you and your loved ones at me on bs,
me undies match and fucking where's Doo Doo Doo Doo beyond these B and e's.
Nobody fucking cares that your wife and you got a shark on your tape and you
tasting tarts.
Sorry.
Talk about why me and these are the best underwear.
Feel free to improvise.
You know I love about me undies.
I don't have to go to the store to get them.
How about that?
All right.
I don't give a fuck about your prints.
They're comfortable.
They fit my bulls and under carriage there,
uh,
me undies uses the coveted micro modal modal fabric,
which is three times softer than cotton.
If you've never felt this fabric,
get ready to experience pure bliss in underwear form.
All right.
As you sashay down the street,
filling your balls,
swishing to and fro this holiday,
season me on these.
We'll be releasing a new print every Tuesday.
That means you have no excuse to celebrate the holidays,
uh,
right down to your very core.
But why stop at me undies this year?
Me undies is launching their holiday prince in lounge pants in one as well.
Both are made from the same micro modal modal fabric as their undies.
Seriously,
how can you not get you and your loved ones and matching holiday theme once he,
this year,
I don't know,
maybe got laid off.
Me undies has a great all bill [inaudible] has a great offer for my listeners.
For any first time purchases.
You Patricia structures,
you can purchase any me undies you get for 15% off and free shipping to get your
15% off your first pair and free shipping and a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's me,
undies.com/burr one more.
Everybody stamps.
Dot Con talk about how the holidays are always the busiest time of year.
You know,
people tell you,
you think you're busy for the first 11 months of the year and then the holidays
come around and you're like,
wow,
this is the busiest time of year.
Sorry,
I'm contractually obligated to do that.
Why do you,
what do you have on your list?
Your holiday list?
I want the Beastie boys hardcover book that they put out,
or is it just Beastie boys?
I never been able to figure that out because they will always call the Beastie
boys and then one time they go,
we're not,
the Beastie boys were Beastie boys,
and then you go back and listen to their first fucking song.
It's like,
ah,
I Bobby,
just jealous when the Beastie boys right.
It's like you fucking said it.
What are you guys,
a bunch of hypocrites like me.
I want the,
I want Beastie boys or I could say the one of my Russian,
I can't use the word though.
I want the the and then quote Beastie boys hardcover book.
That's what I want.
I want that in a little fucking peace and quiet where I can go read it.
Um,
all right,
wait.
[inaudible]
I think I actually liked their instrumental albums as much as the ones that they
wrap on,
the ones that they hip hop on.
I'm too white to know anything about this shit,
but I liked that band back the back bay.
A
two.
Okay.
Where am I?
How many errands do you have to run?
I don't think it's any of your fucking business.
How was stamps.com helping you to save times this holiday?
US.
He's a,
well,
I can mail out all my Christmas gifts right from the come from my own home
wherein me on days beyond these Bob Adap,
ADAP out whack.
I conducted Derek,
I connect.
Sorry.
That was a remix.
Um,
how has stamps dot.
I already answered that.
As you know,
the holidays are the busiest time of
year am I am.
I stuck in like a fucking loop here,
especially at the post office.
That's why we use stamps.com it saves us so much time during the hectic holiday
season with all the time and money you'll save.
stamps.com is the best gift you can give yourself this holiday season and right
now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that includes
a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top,
the homepage and type in Berbee.
You are that stamps.com and to burry [inaudible] wait,
there's another read.
All right,
I'm waiting for that one.
Okay.
You guys have listened to me.
Read out loud,
but then I'm going to forget it.
If I don't do it,
I'm going to forget it.
A Jesus.
What do I do here?
What do you guys,
I'm gonna let you guys vote.
Okay.
Call in one 800 red pubes and let me know.
All right,
now I'm going to read it.
Okay,
here we go.
Um,
my bookie,
everybody a and one place a bed,
but you didn't continue with where you,
the big well in team over there this thanksgiving,
it's finally possible to get 100% refund on your bed if you lose it.
What on your family,
how could they fucking miss?
Uh,
with the Turkey Day free play?
You can bet on this.
You can bet the spread on either the bears or the lions.
Why am I reading this?
This already happened.
If it wins you in,
if it loses my book,
you will get books and these guys are trustworthy,
fast and helpful.
So you know they're good for it.
New To sports betting.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
Okay,
I can read this shit here cause this is just,
you can read this anyway.
A nudist sports betting and have a lot of questions.
That's okay too because my bookies,
patient,
customer service can teach you how to gamble on sports.
Sign up this week and my book,
He will give you a 50% deposit bonus to jumpstart your bank row.
It's a great way to bank even more money when you win.
Log onto my bookie right now.
When you use the Promo Code Berbee you are are to get 50% off.
Uh,
if they don't get 50% deposit bone,
it says Promo Code Bar.
You need a,
you don't need a promo code for your Turkey Day.
Free play.
That's over.
All right.
All right,
we're done.
Okay.
There we go.
We ain't got [inaudible] to do.
All right.
Um,
there was something I wanted to talk about.
Yeah.
Black Friday.
I'm,
we got to look that up.
Let's see.
Did anybody,
why is it called [inaudible]?
It's an accounting term.
You're in the black,
right?
If you're in the red.
Well,
isn't that not sensitive to native?
You know,
Gigi should.
Alright.
Um,
black
fry,
they
injuries
2018,
you know,
some piece of shit.
Lawyers also
googling this black Friday death count.
Oh wait.
Oh eight two injured and stabbing at New York Mall on Black Friday.
My fault man,
shopping on black Friday at Walmart has apparent heart attack and dies.
Coroner says,
man injured in shooting in New Jersey.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ people.
Is it really worth it to,
to,
to go out and get the fucking deep fryer you or whenever the hell it is you're
looking for.
I'm telling you,
you shop on Saturday.
You walk in like a gentleman.
All right.
200 and stabbing in New York Mall.
Now you wonder,
did the person bring the knife there just in case they didn't quite get to the
fucking nerf football fast enough.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't like making fun of people with not a lot of money who have to go and do
shit like this,
but that there's no reason to stab somebody over a fucking microwave.
Is there?
Um,
I mean,
you can shoot somebody over a refrigerator,
but we're talking to microwave here.
I mean,
you can get one of those like 30 bucks.
All right,
Sarah,
choose New York.
Two men have been stabbed at a confrontation at a central New York Mall amid
black Friday shopping.
This couldn't have been about this.
I feel like the violence only happens at Walmart.
Am I crazy?
Allegedly.
Alright.
Syracuse police tell local media outlets.
It happened around 4:15 PM at destiny USA police and the mall manager management
say the dispute began at Mace at the Macy's store.
It's not immediately clear what sparked the confrontation.
Well,
if you're in Macy's,
I imagine it's the men department and they were looking at a couple of button
downs there.
A officer's found one man wounded in the abdomen and another man wounded
elsewhere on his body.
That means he gets stabbed in the groin.
Both are in their twenties and were taken to a hospital managing just laying
under a clothes,
clothes rack.
Just looking up at this shirt that was so fucking important eight seconds ago,
please say the injuries don't appear.
Life threatening,
uh,
photos by syracuse.com and ws.
Why our TV show,
a portion of Macy's and another store's entrance were taped off for a time.
Uh,
destiny USA managers say saying a statement,
the bloodshed was an isolated incident that that's absolutely unacceptable.
There you go,
buddy.
Make,
make,
make a strong stand and strengthens our resolve to remain vigilant.
What does that mean?
Okay,
that's the statement.
Listen,
those were the y'all.
This is,
this is the,
of all that.
Listen,
those were the only two people that got stabbed at Destiny USA,
uh,
which is absolutely not acceptable to stab someone at this small.
And,
uh,
we're now gonna try,
to,
you know,
really look at people,
do make sure there's no stabbing motions towards another customer.
Yeah.
Are we really going to get to the point in this country where you're gonna have
to have a metal detector in a fucking clothing store?
All right,
man.
Shopping on black Friday at Walmart has a heart attack.
He must've got to the Billy Best first and he couldn't fucking imagine as look.
Oh,
Bill.
Really?
I'm sorry.
What am I?
This is a fucking comedy podcasts.
They have to make fun of things.
[inaudible] air.
Alright.
Wham,
wham,
wham.
Bonk,
bonk out.
All right.
A man died Friday after having an apparent heart attack while shopping at the
Walmart waned.
Sorry.
This is the Walmart,
right?
They'll take this job and shove it.
I work in here no more.
That's my fairly bash.
You put that damn mother fucker all right.
At the Walmart on the u s to 80
in Phenix city authority.
Say where the fuck is Fenix looks like Phoenix,
but it's not.
It's Phenix city.
All right.
Little geography lesson.
Everybody.
All right,
here we go.
I x,
Phoenix City,
Alabama.
Oh,
Jim,
give me a break.
This is probably against fucking a Bam.
A fucking,
uh,
War Eagle Fin.
It's a city in Lee and Russell counties in the state of Alabama.
Oh,
it's almost in Georgia.
It's almost in Georgia.
That's the funniest thing about,
at the,
as they looked down on Alabama.
Fucking hilarious.
Wait Lot Graham.
Shit.
We Polish our boots.
All right.
A man died Friday after having an apparent heart attack while shopping at the
Walmart on us to 80 in Phenix city.
Authority said the death during Black Friday shopping was a sad note to the
holiday season.
Oh,
here's,
here's a,
um,
a little side note as a toddler drowned in his big gulp that he drove,
they dropped
and whatever.
It's black Fridays,
some black humor,
um,
witnesses on Facebook expressing their condolences.
Russell County Coroner said Teddy Venable 71 ah,
I feel bad.
This is somebody's grandfather had a heart of the history of heart problems.
He was pronounced.
All right,
so that doesn't have anything to do with Walmart.
Yeah,
he hits you.
Let's get the guy in the history of heart problems.
He made it to 71 God bless them,
I hope for is peace of he was a fucking Bama fan rather than Auburn.
Yeah.
So he had more joy in his life.
He probably was.
I bet he was.
That's what kept him going.
All right,
man.
Injured in shooting.
Okay.
See where we go from here.
Jesus Christ,
all these,
he shows a glock when you get here.
All right,
man.
Injured and shooting and New Jersey Mall,
Elizabeth,
New Jersey.
The waning hours at black Friday were disrupted in New Jersey Mall on Friday as
a man was wounded by gunfire shortly after 8:00 PM.
That is way too early in the evening to get shot.
What did the guy who got shot say,
I'm actually,
I'm going to side with the shooter on this one.
You know what I mean?
You should somebody around midnight.
Then thena here.
You're fucking drunk ass all,
but you shoot somebody at 8:00 AM and 8:00 PM they deserved it.
All right.
The man was shot in the wrist,
in a hallway between the marshals and Tommy Hilfiger stores at the Mills,
at Jersey Gardens in Elizabeth.
All right.
The shooter was,
has not been caught in.
The victim is not cooperating with the authorities.
All right,
this is gang related.
This has nothing to do.
Okay.
There you go.
See?
You know what too?
Those are really only just one stabbing at Macy's.
Another guy had a history of heart problems.
You know we went there.
The the fucking,
I don't know what the hedge clippers were still there.
He couldn't believe it.
He fucking had a heart attack.
Yeah,
that guy.
they did that shit.
You know,
get shot in the wrist day.
I'm not going.
What happened Jan?
I don't know.
You sit there and put a bullet in your fucking risks and you're not cooperate.
That is gang related.
I'm going to go out on out on a limb there.
All right,
Bill,
can we get back to the podcast?
[inaudible] I'm gonna make you guys hate that song.
Sorry.
All right,
let's get to a little,
so let's get to some of the questions here.
All right.
Gaslighting.
Hey,
Billy.
Truck,
nuts.
Um,
anyone,
what that means.
I heard you and Nia talking about gaslighting.
I thought you might find it interesting that the origin of that word comes from
in 1944 movie called gaslight.
Yes.
Somebody sent this to me.
This is really interesting.
It's about a husband that systematically manipulates little things in her
environment to get her to think she's crazy.
One example is when he dimmed the gas lights in the house,
she mentioned to her husband about the dim lights and he would pretend that they
were fine.
The wiki page explains it.
Well,
longtime lay listener and love the show.
I'm going to have to watch that.
All right,
go to the page.
Here we go.
Let's read.
All right.
Gaslighting I taught gaslighting was you.
You're like blowing somebody up.
You know,
saying that they were better than they were.
It turns out it was the exact opposite.
It's a form of psychological manipulation that seeks to sow the seeds of doubt
in a targeted individual or in a member of a targeted group,
making them question their own memory.
Perception,
insanity.
Using persistent denial,
misdirection,
counter diction,
and lying.
I feel like persistent denial,
misdirection encountered contradiction.
That's more like,
that's more finessed.
The lying is just,
yeah,
that's just gorilla pimping,
right?
You just fucking punching him in the face and attempts to destabilize the victim
and de legitimize the victim's belief.
Uh,
instances may range from the denial by an abuser that the previous abusive
incidents ever occurred.
Oh,
this is what your parents always say.
that never happened.
Um,
opt to staging of bizarre events by the abuser with the intention of
disorienting the victim.
All right.
Guess what I'm going to watch tonight?
I'm gonna Watch that movie.
Gaslighting,
uh,
again is a gas lighting,
gas lighting,
um,
movie called gaslight.
Yeah.
I got to watch that.
Anything in black and white,
I fucking,
I really enjoy including one of my specials.
Sorry.
Advice for the fellow cubicle warriors.
Hey,
Billy Wonka.
Huh?
Now.
How did nobody ever come up with that one?
Billy Walker.
I recently changed my life by setting all my devices tonight mode,
permanently phone,
laptop,
iPad.
I had the standard headache and I paid some all these screens in my face all day
long.
We got to buy those glasses that they gave me.
The Blue Tint on him.
Yeah.
What did went away over here?
It's to the point now when someone shows me their iPhone,
I kind of pull back cause I can feel those blue lights wrapping my brain.
I think it's something you and your listeners should know.
Oh,
you said everything tonight.
night mode.
Oh,
so it's not as bright in your face.
Well,
you know,
it'd be great if you show me how to do that.
I could probably look that up.
I like the direction you're going in,
sir.
Any sort of paranoia is right in my fucking wheel offs.
Uh,
my first comedy show,
what's the etiquette?
Oh,
sit there and shut the fuck up.
Laugh if it's funny.
If you want to heckle Haeckel but don't be a baby anyways.
Hi Bill.
Big Fan.
So glad that you're coming to Germany out.
Jesus,
this is somebody from another country.
There's no comedy in Germany or it's they laughing.
Um,
I have just bought a ticket to your first show of the tour,
the one in Cologne,
uh,
on June 4th of January.
By the way,
I learned the last time Cologne,
Germany was one of the number one bombed cities in World War II and there's
still a few buildings that survived a big fans.
So glad that you were coming to Germany.
I've just bought a ticket for your first show in that tour.
Uh,
the one in Cologne.
I had the best time when I was there last time.
Uh,
so I'm anticipating it's going to be another great show.
This will be the first comedy show I go to in my whole life.
I moved to Germany two years ago.
Before that I lived in Moldova.
I'll small and insignificant country that bright stars don't go to any ways.
Do you think that on one of your podcasts episodes,
you could take a minute or two to explain how these comedy shows go for you?
What does the ideal spectator like?
Should I bring flowers and give them to you on stage?
I this guy,
this guy is going to heckle the shit out of me.
And how do you get the chance to meet you after the show?
It would be a real honor to be able to do so.
Thank you all the best to you and your family and I wish you a great European
Troy,
uh,
tour.
Um,
this is,
you go there,
you sit down,
you get yourself a drink and then you listen to the comedians.
If what they say is funny,
you laugh at what if it isn't,
don't laugh.
And uh,
if you go too long without laughing,
then you heckle.
I mean,
that's a part of it.
I hate to tell that to an audience member.
But that's true.
And I think that that's one of the great things about standup comedy is the
heckling.
It's a great thing about politics too.
You know,
it's fun,
but it sucks as a politician cause you can't tell them to go fuck themselves.
You know?
Look,
well,
let me ask you this.
Why did you raise the taxes in our county?
Because you're fucking your sister in that fucking pig trough.
Yep.
Hayseed content that gets an applause break in my business.
That ends your career as a politician.
Although Donald Trump,
president Trump has shown that maybe that isn't the case.
Um,
I am so excited for this European tour.
I am,
I am clean living Billy until I get out there,
you know what I mean?
And I'm not going to fuck it up either because I'm taping a special in March,
I believe of next year.
So,
um,
I had my last bit of fun.
Um,
this weekend I am done.
No cigars,
no fucking booze,
no bread,
no cookies,
no chips,
no,
no nothing.
And uh,
I'm shutting it down during the,
during the toughest time of the year.
And uh,
I feel fucking good about it.
Eight hours sleep and I'm drinking fucking waters.
And this includes right through the rose bowl because I'm sad to announce
that
the,
literally the cornerstone of the tailgate can't make it this year because he's
got a Gig.
Uh,
the,
the five star Chef Jason Law had.
Okay.
Unfortunately,
due to circumstances beyond his control cannot be there this year.
And um,
it,
it's,
yeah,
that's like,
you know,
he's going to be there next year,
hopefully.
You know,
who knows if he keeps fucking getting gigs,
I don't know.
But this is like,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm hoping it's just this year,
but the fact did,
he's not going to be there.
I mean,
you know,
he does his Reggie Jackson impression,
he fucking just crushes it with the breakfast sandwiches.
He just made it just,
it's like a massive,
you know,
this is like Derek Jeter retirement.
Oh,
I was,
I'm just going to say he's out with an injury.
So we're going to go easier.
I think we're going to go easier this year,
do it a little bit differently,
but I'm not going to be boozing,
um,
at all done with this shit.
I got to get myself a tip top condition because I am not a young man anymore.
And that,
that European tour is a 10 cities in 10 nights.
MMM.
And it's just,
yeah.
So I'm,
and a lot of those places I haven't been to ever,
so I cannot go there and fuck up.
I have to go there and be,
you know,
I gotta be in my best on my best behavior.
Got To help him not on planes every fucking day.
MMM.
But if I am going to be,
the last thing I need to be doing is fucking going out there acting like a
fucking idiot.
All right.
Here we go.
Uh,
drinking as a college freshman.
Speaking of boozing,
dear bill,
I'm a college freshman,
freshmen and just recently went to my first dorm party that wasn't held in my
room.
It's hilarious.
You sound like me back in the day.
I'm an introvert.
So luckily for me,
I got a roommate who is social and likes to party.
Otherwise,
I'd probably be spending all my time,
my room and not interacting with anybody.
Well,
that's good.
Good.
Get yourself out there.
It doesn't mean you've got to be an idiot though.
All right?
You got to drink responsibly.
Actually,
you're not supposed to be drinking because you're under age.
Look at me.
I'm a dad now.
Uh,
I mostly kept to myself throughout high school and had a few friends but never
really,
really did much with them outside of school.
Uh,
because of that,
I never had any alcohol.
I'm not much of a party guy,
but I want to step out of my comfort zone.
So I started,
decided to go.
It sounds like the beginning of it.
Yeah.
A really interesting movie.
Oh God.
Okay.
So you go in there.
All right.
Um,
hey,
this is the thing for all you young people out there.
If you've never really done something before,
the best thing you could do is tell people that you haven't just fucking own it.
Yeah.
I never,
I never drank any more.
I'm a little nervous about it.
I just want to go easy.
Just give me one here and they'll all lap or they'll,
they'll like it.
It's when you act like you've been there before and that's when you get in
trouble.
I'm not much of a party guy,
but I wanted to step out of my comfort zone,
so I decided to go.
A bet includes even being a virgin.
Yeah.
Do you know,
where's the fucking shy?
Never,
never banged anybody.
It hasn't happened for me.
Help me out guys.
Yeah.
Then it,
then you get,
you have,
you get brings people together.
Let's get them lake.
Yeah,
just don't go to a hook.
Uh,
I'm not much of a party guy,
but I wanted to step out of my comfort zone.
So I decided to go for my lack of experience.
It seemed pretty wild.
There was lots of alcohol,
mostly hard liquor,
vaping making out and loud rap music that I didn't know the lyrics to.
Dude,
you are hilarious,
man.
This guy's a writer.
Um,
it really painted.
Yeah.
Being the sheltered person that I am,
I stayed in the corner and just observed everyone else.
I was approached by a few people that offer to alcohol,
but I kindly refuse.
That's good.
You're a strong person saying that I would drink something else.
I realized that the alcohol would helped me loosen up.
So it was pretty tempting,
but not having any experience with it.
I decided not to smart man using your head.
Even though I kept to myself for the most part,
I had some fun and I'm looking forward to the next party.
I am,
I am a pretty small person on and five pounds soaking wet and about five feet,
seven inches tall.
So it wouldn't take much for me to feel the effects.
Um,
I am mostly afraid of how I would act and what I would say.
Dude,
you're a very smart person.
A college is all about new experiences,
right?
So what do you think?
Should I drink the next time a party at a party or gathering comes up?
If so,
what advice do you have?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I dunno,
you're underage so I can't tell you to go drink.
You shouldn't do.
If if I,
if how I would,
I wish I would've handled she situations like that.
I just tell you roommate that that's the deal.
I never really drank or anything like that and I would stay in your dorm room
and just drink a beer.
I would do that and then tell your roommate to say,
Hey,
can you do me favor?
Just look out for me.
At this party.
I don't want to do with say anything stupid.
Right.
And then on top of that,
when you go to the party,
don't fucking,
don't get crazy as long as you got to,
as long as you sitting there with a beer in your hand,
you can legally have water in them,
in the canned for all they know and just be sipping a,
you know,
but it's a very mature thing that you're already considering not being out of
control.
So I wouldn't do that.
Okay.
You shouldn't drink if you're under age.
You shouldn't.
I did.
It was stupid.
I got in a lot of trouble and it ended with me getting fucking arrested in me.
Finally fucking smarten up.
Really in the really,
the reality is,
is,
you know,
nothing good comes from it.
It's not good for you.
It's not good for you health wise.
Um,
it's not,
it's not good.
It's just not good for you.
Um,
you put on,
you're going to put on the wrong kind of weight if you do.
However,
when you're of age,
occasionally having a beer is the way you do it.
If you were mature person,
here I am,
50 years of fucking agent,
I still have to shut it down because I don't even know how to do it.
Um,
so they know that that is the world that you're going into.
So I think it's good that you're very cautious.
Um,
having said that,
there's other ways to have fun,
but you know,
you want to meet some women or whatever,
so just fucking go,
you know,
it's a strong move.
These would go there and you're not drinking.
You know what I mean?
But then it gets weird if you start talking to a woman and she's been drinking
and then you haven't,
and then she wants to fucking hook up,
then it's this weird fucking,
yeah,
it gets,
it gets fucking weird man.
Um,
I would,
you know what I would do,
I would explore the place,
other ways to be social.
Go to the fucking party,
don't fucking drink.
You know,
you'll be ahead of the game.
Um,
and then I would find other,
other social activities.
I mean,
you're not the only person at school that doesn't drink.
You know,
maybe you can meet some fucking responsible,
you know,
woman have a good time.
That way.
There's a lot of ways to skin the cat.
And I'm really outside my element because I was the idiot that went to the
fucking party and did shitty in school.
So
there you go.
You don't have to drink,
you know,
have to fucking have a beer.
Uh,
all right to press girlfriend,
just no,
dude,
you're totally in control and there's nothing wrong with anything about you,
anything that you're doing.
And uh,
and a lot of ways she's stronger than most other people because they're just
doing what everybody else is doing,
which is the easiest thing.
Right?
And you'll see it in your lifetime.
Whenever he douche bag goes out and gets themselves a fucking robot because
their neighbor has one.
All right to press girlfriend.
Hello Billy [inaudible] Billy blue balls.
Um,
so recently I've started a relationship with the girl and uh,
she told me that she needed to tell me something very important that I might not
like about her.
Uh,
she told me that she had been diagnosed as depressed for several years.
Mind you,
I've only known this girl for several months and I don't know her circumstances.
Is this a deal breaker?
Do I break up with their,
should I ignore it?
If I break up with her,
is she going to harm herself?
The situation puts me in a bad position and I am not sure what to do.
I think she regrets telling me because she doesn't want me to judge her.
Also,
I am a younger male still in high school and I feel like I am not mature enough
to deal with this situation.
Help us appreciate it.
Ah,
all right.
Okay.
Number one,
anytime you have a problem,
you should never ignore it cause all it does is just get bigger.
MMM.
Is this a deal breaker?
Do I break up with her?
These are all decisions you have to make.
Um,
as far as you breaking,
if you do break up with it,
is it going to harm her?
He,
it's,
it's not your,
your responsibility in life is your happiness when it comes to relationships.
Okay.
And if you're in something you don't want to be in,
in a nice,
respectful way,
you sit down with the person,
you tell them you're not happy,
that you liked them.
You just don't like him in a way where you want to continue and then you don't
just not talk to him.
You can still be friends with them and stuff like that.
You just,
you don't have to be a fucking asshole about it.
However,
though,
if,
you know,
if at the end,
all of this shit,
what this person is bringing to the table is not what you're into,
then there's nothing wrong with breaking up with them.
Um,
there's plenty of ways for her to get help.
It's not your responsibility that she has been diagnosed as depressed.
Um,
but you know,
I,
I would talk to her about it and just say like,
you know what?
It's what,
it's
how it makes you feel just yet.
I don't want to just silly,
I'm not judging.
We all got our,
our issues or whatever.
Um,
you know,
I would just talk to her and learn more about it.
Learn,
how is it,
how,
how deep is it?
You know,
she laid on the floor for weeks and can't get out of the fucking house.
I mean,
you know,
I mean that's,
that's,
that's a lot to take on.
And someone who's out there with butterfly flies swirling around your head.
If you're not having a fucking problem,
know it's,
it's all going to be up to you.
But I would not ignore it.
I would just sit down and talk to her about it and then digest it and then see
how you're feeling about it and whatever your gut is telling you to do,
I would do.
And if it's stay with her,
I would stay with during,
if it's says to leave,
leave,
but do what you know.
You don't have to be mean when you break up with somebody.
And one of the worst things ever is they don't teach people how to break up with
people.
Uh,
I,
there should just be a fucking class on that.
And like the masters of it are the ones who can break up with somebody and they
can still be friends with them
is an incredible thing.
But,
and,
but I,
and you know,
and I think the only way to do that is it from day one,
you're just honest and you're constantly checking in emotionally about where
you're at.
Because if you don't,
and it's going off the rails and you know,
it's off the rails and the other person doesn't,
that's when somebody feels like they got dumped.
But if you're talking the whole way along,
the other person kind of knows it's good,
still sucks.
It's still going to be painful,
but it's not that fucking like,
where did that come from?
And then the next thing you know,
she's standing outside your fucking bedroom window with a pair of sharpen
scissors.
All right?
So there you go.
That's the podcast.
It's a little bit short this week,
but,
uh,
I gotta I gotta figure out how to fucking download Skype again so I can do this
other bullshit or whatever.
All right.
Ah,
that's it everybody.
I hope you all had a great thanksgiving.
I hope you all have great thanksgiving.
I hope you didn't get trampled on black Friday.
I will check in on you on Thursday.
I'm enjoy Monday night football tonight,
and once again,
please watch,
uh,
I know you already listened to it,
but if you haven't listened to the Joe Rogan experience,
I'll be there Wednesday,
uh,
spitting chiclets Wednesday,
Barstool sports that I'm doing dice Clay's podcast.
Um,
I don't know when that one's going to be uploaded.
I don't know how he does it.
I've never done this podcast,
but,
uh,
that's what I'll be doing this week.
Kevin had been on Friday.
Okay.
Get your Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit tickets and lastly,
but not leastly.
What was the other thing?
Um,
oh,
F is for family.
Jesus Christ.
November 29th,
Netflix.
Please sit down and watch it.
All right.
See you.